Some content in
this video is not
covered under our
Creative Commons license.
See the closing credits
for more information.
SARA JAMES: Hello my
name is Sara James.
I've been working
the past seven years
at MIT Lincoln Laboratory,
doing radar signal processing.
Today, I'm here to tell you
about the image processing
workshop of the girls who build.
So the image processing
section of this workshop
is actually done with a
software called Processing.
Processing is open
source, free, and it's
available at Processing.org
to download, for just
about any sort of operating
system that you can think of.
This software is
actually developed
for people that are not
doing coding, day to day.
During this section
of the workshop
we're trying to
expose participants
to image processing
concepts, within the context
of real world applications.
Furthermore, we're trying to
demystify coding, and show
participants that
they can do this too.
You'll be doing four exercises.
The first being an
Instagram filter.
For the Instagram
filter this will
be adding an overlay where
you can change the RGB values.
Next you'll be
flipping an image.
This will be a flip
that's vertical,
and during this you'll
be actually moving
around the individual pixels.
After this, you will
convert a color image
to a different color scheme.
So you'll take something, and
convert it to one single color.
This involves modifying
the individual color values
for every pixel.
For the last exercise,
which is the vignette,
this is adding a
border to the picture.
The way that this is performed,
is by doing a mask overlay.
Before you just jump into
having the girls doing
the fill in the blank exercises,
it's highly recommended
to go over the four processing
components of any processing
program.
The first is
variable Declaration:
this is where you
initialize something
as being a PImage or
perhaps a Boolean,
depending on the exercise.
Next is the setup.
The setup is where you
generally load in images
and initialize the various
settings for a program.
After that you'll have a Draw.
Draw is where you
actually produce the frame
that you'll see.
Lastly you'll have, in some of
the exercises, Mouseclicked.
And this is to handle
mouse click events.
Before breaking the
girls up into groups,
we had a image
processing lecture,
that was specifically tailored
towards the processing
language.
During this lecture,
various fundamentals
of image processing
were introduced
like color schemes--
for instance RGB
or things like HSBC-- in
discussing brightness.
After the processing lecture,
we broke up the girls
into groups of four, with
one volunteer per group.
When the girls were
broken up, they
were given their exercises.
These exercises were set up as
fill in the blank activities.
The fill in the
blank style was done
to level the playing
field, so that people
with more or less
experience with coding
would feel comfortable.
Time permitting--
and also dependent
on the experience
level of the girls
that you're working with--
there's additional activities
that you can do, within the
context of the four coding
exercises that have
already been defined.
For the first one, for your
build your own Instagram
filter, you can actually
modify the RGB values
to change the overlay.
So this is something that's
relatively easy to do,
and something that
you should definitely
encourage the girls to do.
For the flip an image, you
can actually change the way
that the images flip.
So in the exercises
that we had, the image
is flipped vertically,
but a more difficult thing
that you can ask
the girls to do,
is to flip the
image horizontally.
So within the convert an
image to a single color,
you can actually ask the
girls to manually convert
to grayscale.
For this activity,
this is something
that's introduce the girls to
the way that color is perceived
by humans.
For the add a vignette,
one relatively easy thing
that you can ask
the girls to do,
is vary the size and
color of the vignette.
Lastly, and this is
the most difficult,
you can actually
ask the participants
to combine all elements,
from all of the exercises.
This is something that
is the most complex,
because it involves
potentially changing
the way that the
code was originally
run in the exercises.
So in terms of the
lessons learned,
there are certain
things that we did not
do, during girls who
build, and in hindsight we
would have done, if we
were to do this again.
One of the first
things is actually
introducing the
fundamentals of programming.
Things like introducing
if statements,
while statements, what a
Boolean is, things like that.
When we had done girls
who build, we kind of just
jumped right into the exercises,
after an image processing
lecture.
And that wasn't really enough
preparation for the girls.
The first exercise was very
difficult to get through.
That's another thing that
you could potentially do.
If you have people that are not
really experienced with coding,
feel free to go through
the first exercise
together, and then have the
students do the following three
exercises individually.
Each individual student
had their own laptop,
don't think that this is
something that you need to do.
You may find that having
multiple students with only one
laptop will be sufficient, and
actually might introduce them
to working in a group, and
the type of collaboration that
entails.
Also along those lines.
If everyone has
their own computer,
you might find that
it's very isolating.
One thing that girls
who build did not do,
but it's something that we
may look into in the future,
is using some sort of
collaborative editing software.
An example of this is TitanPad.
Whether you're a
student or a teacher,
you may be asking yourself,
what are the next steps?
The next steps could
possibly be looking
into other coding languages.
Coding languages that you may
want to look into include c++,
Java, or Python.
You'll find that, for
instance, if you wanted
to build an Android
app, there's communities
and resources available
online for free.
That you can access.
Have fun with the image
processing activity!
We'd love to hear
about your experience.
Email:
Girls Who Build.
Girlswhobuild.org